hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the key
topics that Aristotle addresses again
and Megha McCann ethics book 10 is the
value of pleasure there were some people
in ancient times just as there are in
our own times who thought that pleasure
was the good that is whatever is good is
good because of that particular good so
we could we call that the good with a
capital G other people have different
views of what makes something good
Aristotle for example sees all goods as
in some way connected with with
eudaimonia or happiness he is not going
to accept the the notion that pleasure
is the good although he certainly does
concede that pleasure is a good and what
we're going to see him doing early on in
book 10 is what we call a dialectical
examination of the various positions he
brings up several arguments for that
position
that namely that pleasure is the good
and then he brings up some counter
arguments against that position and it
considers each of them in terms and some
of the arguments that he doesn't
consider to be particularly good
arguments are going to be balanced by or
attacked by or critiqued by other
arguments that he also doesn't consider
to be particularly good arguments
there's something wrong with them so
let's look at each of these in turn he
talks about dosas who said all of these
various points you notices argued that
the creatures all seek to obtain
pleasure so therefore it is the most
desirable thing and whatever is most
desirable is the good Aristotle thinks
that there's something to this argument
but he's going to consider it a bit
later so how the argument concludes is
that because of the famine of all
creatures move in the direction of the
same thing that is pleasure that thing
is the supreme good that was just good
for all of which all seek to obtain is
the good with a capital G so that's one
argument
another argument is that since pain is
the object of avoidance for all things
everything insofar as can feel pain
tries to avoid pain and we human beings
most of all we have you know pain
killers husband some other things that
we use you know compensations for pain
that means that since pleasure is the
opposite of pain pleasure must be the
good if pain is what is primarily bad
since everything tries to avoid it
pleasure must be the highest good
another thing that he brings up is the
fact that pleasure is chosen for its own
sake and Aristotle has this interesting
little quip in there
if you ask somebody hey why are you
engaging in that Plus
to activity and they say for the
pleasure involved and then you say yeah
why do you want that pleasure involved
isn't there something beyond the
pleasure itself at the pleasure is
leading to if they look at you with sort
of a blank stare
Aristotle says well that's a healthy
individual you know you know he doesn't
talk in these terms but we could imagine
somebody in our own time who rations out
to themselves
I'll only allow myself this amount of
pleasure this day because you know I
need a little bit of pleasure in order
to not feel totally upset about things
you know this could be a conch in this
could be somebody engaging and positive
psychology there's all sorts of ways in
which we could frame this where pleasure
itself becomes an instrumental good for
something else and every cell says
that's not really the case pleasure is
indeed something that we do desire for
its own sake so maybe there's something
to that argument another issue that's
brought up is that this is an
interesting argument as well and a
pleasure to some other good makes that
good better so why would this be the
case presumably that would be the case
precisely because pleasure is a kind of
good that can be attitude and therefore
underlie all the other goods you can
increase the quantum of pleasure if we
want to talk in hedonistic or invaded
utilitarian terms about about this sort
of idea so when each of these is an
argument that's being made for the good
being pleasure not just pleasure being a
good but pleasure being the primary and
fundamental good look now as some of the
arguments made against this position
which aren't quite interesting so
Aristotle says that one way to try to
counter
this argument of saying all creatures
desire pleasure therefore pleasures is
the best good thing is to say well what
all creatures seek isn't good
and the arrows it's something very
interesting to say about that he says
those who deny that that which all
creatures seek to obtain as good are
surely talking nonsense for what all
things to be good that we assert is good
and he that subverts our belief in the
opinion of all mankind will hardly
persuade us to believe his own either
now he made some concessions he says
well maybe only the irrational creatures
that is you know bogs and dogs and pigs
and things like that maybe they were the
ones that seek pleasure and human beings
don't and then he says well that's not
the case just look around - human beings
desire pleasure and seek out pleasure
we haven't entertained the industries in
our own time basically founded on that
and Aristotle says earlier than a
committee ethics we actually have crafts
technique that are that are founded and
on producing pleasure life the culinary
arts so it's clear though that we do in
fact desire some some pleasures so he
says you know it as much as beings
endowed with intelligence do so how can
this argument be right and he also
considers this issue of the argument of
pleasure being that good because pain is
the bad now some people could oppose to
that another argument which which is in
a certain respect correct they can say
well you can be opposed to evil or it
can be opposed to something that's
neither good nor evil so if we know that
pain is evil and pleasures its opposite
that doesn't necessarily mean that
pleasure is even good let alone love
good so this would be an argument used
to just sort of undermine that that Depp
argument from from opposites and he says
if both pleasure and pain were in the
class of evils both would be a miss
things to be avoided even the class of
things neutral neither ought to be
avoided or they ought to be avoided
alike but what has experience show us
people avoid pain as evil and choose
pleasure as good so this argument
doesn't really hold up that well it
couldn't be
perhaps proved that pleasure is not that
good but it certainly doesn't prove that
pleasure is good so that's not going to
work some of the other arguments that he
brings up that people make against
pleasure being the good are a bit
metaphysical so you know one is that
pleasure is not a quality that is it's
not in the category to a poem quality
that the way in which a thing is so it's
not good and Aristotle says well you
know just remember we've talked about
this in another video good is spoken of
in many ways the the category of good
the good overflows the categories of
predication so good can be in terms of
substance good can be in terms of
quality good can be in terms of quantity
who can be in terms of relation and so
on and he brings up the specific example
of virtues and says well they're good
now of course he does consider virtues
to be in a certain respect quality so
there's a little bit of incoherence in
that argument here's another very
interesting argument the good and this
is a metaphysical principle it is
definite that is it has boundaries it's
not just whatever we want to make of it
pleasure on the other hand has degrees
and Aristotle says well yes the good is
definite but the good also admits of
degrees as well one person can be more
courageous than another person and some
courage admits of degrees one person can
be more just than another person so
justice
of degrees and courage and justice are
forms of goodness so um you know this
argument isn't going to work he brings
up another one as well saying health
health is a good thing but health itself
admits of degrees you can be closer to
being sick closer to being healthy so
the other argument doesn't work very
well either now that we get to one
that's very very about physical pleasure
is a motion or process of generation and
since no motion or process of generation
is perfect and the good with a capital G
is perfect pleasure cannot be that good
and Aristotle I'm not going to go
through the entire argument here
Aristotle says well your premise is
incorrect here because pleasure is not a
motion a convey cyst and it's not a
process of generation against this so
you're starting with bad you know and
you're starting with bad premises
anything you're going to infer from that
is not really going to follow where we
get to the argument that Aristotle is
willing to accept as a good argument
against pleasure being not good it is an
older one that we see coming up in play
some of these other ones have come up in
played out as well that is the
disreputable 'ti of certain pleasures if
pleasure is the good then that would
seem to mean that every pleasure as
pleasure is automatically good is indeed
the best thing that we can have
everything else would be good insofar as
it conduces to or contributes to or
protects or provides pleasure Aristotle
says not all pleasures can be you know
looked at in the same light we make
differences between them some pleasures
are considered to be problematic and not
just be not just because they in some
way interfere
or lesson other plungers so aerosol says
we could in fact weaken this argument we
could deny that these are really
pleasant for granted they're pleasant
ill-conditioned people cannot be assumed
that they're actually pleasant accepted
that this is something he has discussed
in other places the good person is the
measure for what is genuine and
genuinely pleasurable or everyone may
take the line that all the pleasures
themselves are desirable they're not
desirable when derived from those
sources just like wealth is desirable
but not if one by treachery or health
not at the cost of eating anything and
everything or we could say that these
pleasures different specific quality
those derive from noble sources are not
the same as those derived from base
sources you know we make a distinction
also between friend and flatter he's
bringing out a lot of ways to sort of
hedge this thing about the disreputable
pleasures but in the end though he says
it seems that pleasure is not the good
and not every pleasure is desirable but
there are certain pleasures superior and
respect to their specific quality or
their source that are desirable in
themselves what does that mean that
shows that the very fact that we can
bring up all of these provisions
actually strengthens this argument
against pleasure being good now if we
come back to some of these these other
issues over here we could make sense of
them the arguments for that position
certainly all creatures do desire
pleasure that means that that pleasure
is desirable in itself but they don't
always desire the right pleasures some
creatures can be damaged human beings
can be corrupted in many different ways
and desire the wrong pleasures pain is
the object of avoidance we've already
dealt with that one pleasure has chosen
for its own sake Aristotle says yeah so
are many other things so is virtue so is
happenings so in his honor
that doesn't mean that pleasure is
somehow encompassing all of those that
would need to be proven an you pleasure
to a good thing makes it better
well yes but we could say the same thing
about any other good thing as a matter
of fact the Gulen is going to be so
complete that adding pleasure to it is
not going to make it better because the
good will already be you might say
complete in itself so what do we have
here the good is not the pleasure is not
love doing but pleasure is a good among
a multitude of different goods now the
question then is how do we understand
pleasure in relation to these other
goods